[Music]
[Music]
Courtney Cox be any better at social
media
on Sunday the friends alum put her spin
on the savage dance challenge and it's
awesome and creepy and well I'll just
let you check it out for yourself
yeah that's Kourt doing the viral tick
tock Oreo with the baby filter from
snapchat and that's the 55 year old
doing the dance with the man filter I
[Music]
mean I gotta give it to her she even
changed into a dark button-up shirt now
that's commitment you just can't unsee
that Canyon
anyway Kourt share the clip on Instagram
alongside the caption dealer's choice
and let's just say people freakin loved
it including her BFF Jennifer Aniston
who hit up the comments writing I am
dying along a string of crying laughing
emojis and a pair of clapping hands
Julianne Moore and Charlie puth also
applauded Courtney with emojis and David
Spade totally nailed it writing is the
gray shirt Rob Lowe or Jared Leto either
way great dancing but wait she really
does look just like Jared Leto thank you
so much that's very nice to hear
interestingly enough back in June Kourt
posted this selfie to Instagram rocking
a beard filter writing Jared Leto vibes
today hashtag feeling gorgeous I love
everything about it
anyway courts savage post isn't the
first time she's flaunted her impressive
dance skills on social media earlier
this month she busted a move to little
Jackie's slide game
that post caught the attention of her
fellow friends alum Matthew Perry who
asked what we are all thinking hi honey
what the hell just happened but nothing
beats the dance with her 15 year old
daughter Coco Arquette Courtney shared
that clip on Instagram back in January
writing want to see your child lose
their patience do a tick-tock with them
hashtag family aerobics
[Music]